In this section, let's continue our final recommendations with a discussion about workspace
layouts.
The first thing that I need to point out is that your workspace layout is entirely up
to the user.
With that established, we do have some recommended layouts for specific tasks and hardware configurations.
Our first recommended layout is for single monitor users doing sequencer editorial, assemblies,
or layout.
The position of your menu tabs is fully customizable, but it is highly recommended that you work
using a split view viewport.
So let's jump into Unreal Engine and change our layout.
The first thing I want to point out is that right now I have a single view in my viewport.
And I want to switch that by moving up to the little three dots in the upper left hand
corner, moving down to my layouts, and setting this as two panes side by side.
You'll notice in other videos I typically have this already set, as this is my preferred
recommended layout.
Now once they're set side by side, I want to make sure under the perspective option
that one of these is set to cinematic control, while the other is set to the default viewport.
This will allow me to move around my viewport without impacting the view of my camera that
is possessed by my camera cuts track.
Once you're all set, you can save any layout that you want by moving up to the windows
tab, moving down here, and selecting to save a layout.
Just select save layout as.
You can also export layouts and share them among other users.
Once you have a layout saved, to load it, all you need to do is move into the load layout
section and choose from any of the user layouts or default layouts that are saved for you
to use.
Let's look at some other options you may consider for other functions.
Here is an example of a single monitor for animation work.
The more expansive viewport and stacking for the sequencer is a layout I recommend as the
animation tools will open up different menus and tabs but also require a larger viewing
area for sequencer.
Next, we have an example of a layout that users can set if they have a dual monitor
or ultra wide monitor hardware configuration.
Once more, I want to emphasize that your working layout is entirely customizable in order to
meet the individual user preferences.
I want to point out again that any workspace layout can be shared among users once it's
saved.
And finally, I want to warn users that on occasion you might run into a bug when switching
back and forth between saved layouts that will cause the engine to crash.
So just be careful.
That's it for this section.
In our next section, we will continue with more of our final recommendations.